哈喽大家,今天的工作流是N8N跟NanoBanana的结合
或许在之前你看到很多人教你用NanoBanana制作出非常炫酷让人惊讶的图片
但是今天我要分享的是N8N和NanoBanana如何制作出一个可以批量生成图片和批量图片合成的工作流
你只要把需要生成的图片放在表格里,点击运行
它就会自动抓取表格中的图片并生成可商用的宣传图
Nano Banana的出现获得了大家一致好评
它的出现意味着AR在图像生成和编辑领域
实现了重大的技术突破
它生成的图像真实度高
AR痕迹少
特别是在人物一致性上表现的尤为突出
像我在这里根据不同的应用场景
让它生成了三组图片
第一组是给它一张产品图
根据我描述的场景生成一张宣传图
第二组是为给它一张参考图
让它模仿构图跟风格
生成一张适用于我们产品的图片
第三组呢
是让它把两张图片融合出一个新的场景
你会看到
它除了逼真之外呢
在细节上也处理的非常好
像这个产品上的文字啊
也居然都是正确的
而且如果你对哪些细节不满意的话
只需要跟它对话
告诉它你想修改的地方
它就帮你解决了
但现在的问题是
虽然我们知道它很强大
但是一张一张生成太慢了
那如果可以批量生成就好了
好消息是
我在这里跑通了两个批量生成图片的工作流
左边是批量生成图片
右边是批量合成图片
你只需要在表格中点击一下运行
就会把表格中的所有图片一次性处理完
图片生成适用于一张图片编辑
像产品营销摄影图
风格转换等等
那图片合成的工作流呢
更适用于两张图片的情况
你可以提供一张产品图
一张模特图或者是场景图
让AR根据你的描述将两个图片融合出一个更具有表现力的图片
同时也能降低你的拍摄成本
OK 接下来我会分享这两个工作流是如何制作的
先看第一个批量生成图片
整个工作流分为三个部分
第一个是获取图片信息
第二个是通过Naroburner生成图片
第三部分是下载生成图片并上传到表格
在开始搭建工作流之前呢
我们需要先准备表格信息
我在这里用的是AirTable
里面需要包含原始图片
跟希望生成图的描述信息
像希望生成图的分辨率啊
对生产图的描述要求啊
以及想要的图片风格
那如果描述不会写的话
可以请JPT帮你写
我在这里以食品产品为例
让他帮我写了十堵
食品产品摄影宣传图的提示词
那就会比较专业啊
会从场景描述啊
灯光给我们提供一些思路
接下来还需要给表格设置状态跟触发按钮
状态呢
是用来帮我们标记图片生成情况的
防止在自动运行时出现遗漏
触发按钮呢
就相当于一个运行开关
点击运行
M8N就会收到一个指令
它会把所有在生成的图片
根据我们的需求来生成一遍
Z为了它能够成功运行
我们需要给它配置一个URL
确保它能够成功连接到N8N
OK点击下拉箭头
点击editfired
这里面你可以修改标题字段
按钮显示的字段跟按钮颜色
Action选择openURL
那这个URL是哪来的呢
其实就是N8N中的Webhook节点产生的
这个节点是我视频中的新面孔
方便大家理解呢
我简单介绍一下
这是一个触发节点
可以理解为一个公开的URL接口
它主要是用来接收外部系统或服务
通过HTTP请求发送的数据
从而触发N8N等自动化工作流程
在这里可以看到有两个URL连接
一个是TestURL
一个是ProductionURL
Test顾名思义就是测试用的
需要我们手动运行才能够连接到它
具体操作方法会在后面给大家演示
那Production URL就是正式启用工作流时用的
也就是当我们打开这个Inactive激活这个工作流时
这个Production URL就会持续生效
直到你关闭它之前都可以随时连接到它
OK我们先用Text URL来演示
在这里我们点击复制Text URL
然后回到AirTable
把它粘贴到下面的URL公式栏
这里需要注意的是我们除了要发送打开N8N工作流的请求之外呢
还需要发送一个RecordID
目的就是要告诉N8N
这个表格要运行批量生成图片的工作流
你在调用信息的时候别调用错了
所以我在后面加了发送查询参数RecordID
那如果你不能代码不会写也没关系
可以点击下面的AR串件公式
让AR帮你写
你只需要告诉他帮我打开这个链接
然后便发送Recult ID,它就会自动帮你写好了
那设置好之后呢,点击保存,这样我们整个工作流就成功了一半了
接下来我们看一下工作流搭建部分
这个工作流是用了比较稳妥的一种方式
它每次读一条数据,确保描述栏的信息能跟图片准确的对应起来,不会出错在图片合成工作流使用的是比较大胆的方法
它可以一次调取Altable中全部的信息
让AI理解信息理解原始图片到最终生成
我在这里只是做一个分享
在实践的时候你可以选择自己喜欢的方式
OK 我们看一下工作流的详细设置
第一部分获取图片信息
在表格中点击执行
Webhook接收到请成之后呢
会运行get create rules节点
它会做两个操作
一个是筛查找到需要编辑的图片
第二个是获取图片信息
所以在get create rules节点
我们需要给状态列子字段做筛选
找出在生成的行
当然它能够成功运行的条件
是需要先配置credential
OK我们点击create new credential
这里需要填你的token
为了获取到这个token呢
我们打开Airtable首页
在头像的下拉菜单找到Bildhub
然后点击Create Token按钮
你可以给它取一个你喜欢的名字
Scopes里添加了权限范围
为了它足够强大呢
建议把所有的权限都给加进去
下面的assess选择你要访问的空间就好了
当然你也可以全部都添加进去
这样你可以用这个token访问Airtable中所有空间
OK,设置完成之后我们点击创建
你就会得到你的token了
我们复制它回到N8N
然后粘贴过去
点击保存
有绿色的消息提示就代表创建成功了
那Result呢,选择Record
Operation选择Search
因为我们要筛选表格中的字段
所以在下面配置好你表格所在的空间
以及它的名字
Fert by Formula就是我们要筛选的字段了
这里我们需要找到状态列里需要带生成的字段
这样信息提取就设置完成了
接下来我们要用Nano Banana来创建图片
这里需要借助的平台是Fall AR
这是一个提供生成式人工智能服务的平台
里面有丰富的AR模型库
因为我之前充值过了
所以我就没换平台
而且它的价格跟Google官网是一致的
一张图片是0.39美分
一美元大概可以生成25次
那如果你觉得这个价格贵了
后面我会分享价格更低的平台
并且还会分享免费薅羊毛的方法
OK我们回归正题
首先要做的是需要先连接他们Credential
来到Fall平台
然后点击APRK
先创建一个K
然后点击Add Case
点击创建
在弹窗下面呢
看到你的K值
就代表创建成功了
OK我们点击Copy Kit备用
接下来我们要看一下Val平台的调用API的方法
以及它配置Credential的方法
点击Explorer找到Nano Banana
选择Texto Image
打开之后呢点击API
它就会告诉我们调用方法
它的请求方式是Post URL地址在这
那验证类型呢是Head
后面干着的是Name Authorization Value至K
有了这些信息之后呢
我们复制这个URL
回到N8N配置一下
Method改成Post
UIL粘贴过来
Authorization选择Generical Corridation Type
然后验证类型选择Head
下面的Head author创建一个新凭证
你可以给它取个名字
方便跟其他凭证做区分
内部就是Authorization
Value是K加空格
然后再粘贴刚才生成的K
OK点击保存
它有绿色消息提示就代表创业成功了
接下来我们设置一下SendBody,配置一下需要拿到Banana帮我们处理的数据
BodyContentType选择JSON,The Best forBody选择UsingJSON
我这里设置了提示词内容跟产品原始图的连接,以及它要生成的格式,还有风格说明
当然你可以截图保存
这里面所有的动态信息都是getGreedRoy节点获取到的,我们对应把它拖过来即可
Prompt就是描述词
ImageUIL就是原始图片的URL
Thread就是宣传图风格信息
OK我们点击测试
我们看到sliders是Inqueue
说明还在对列生存中
所以我们需要在后面加一个等待节点
确保它有足够的时间生存
顺利进入下一个节点
所以在wait节点
我设置了让它等待15秒
图片生存成功之后呢
我们需要有一个获取结果
也就是获取生成的图片
OK我们看一下这个节点是如何配置呢
还是回到4AI的nano-banana API页面
往下拉找到get result
我们可以复制这个curl回到n8n
然后通过importcurl导入
可能会有朋友好奇啊
为什么这里可以通过curl导入
前面生成图片的节点不用这个方法呢
那是因为前面图片生成节点的curl是一个
需要脚本命令,N8N只能支持HTTP请求参数配置
所以前面就只能用手动配置了
OK,这里配置一下request id
我们先把它切换成表达式的格式
然后把for图片生成节点的request id 拖过来就好了
接下来配置一下credential
按同样的操作步骤,然后选择刚才创建的凭证就好了OK,我们点击测试一下在右边输出了一个URL
打开链接可以看到nanobranner生成的图片
这样图片创建部分就完成了
接下来我们需要把图片上传到Altable
因为URL不能上传
所以我们需要先给它下载下来
把它转成64位的字符串之后再上传
我这里是用http节点获取前面图片的URL
结点获取前面图片的URL,下载它
所以,Method是get,就是获取结果结点输出生存图的URL
获取到之后,它会向URL所带的服务器发起下载图片请求
所以,我在Option这里添加了一个Response Format
请求的响应是FIRL文件
Pull Output in FIRL,输出字段,名为Data
我们就可以通过extract from far节点,将它转化为64位的字符串
在Operation这里,我们选择mode file to basic for string
import binary file是data,destination are preferred,目标输出字段也是data
OK,点击测试,在右边看到它已经转化成功了
OK,对关键的地方来了,就是看它如何把它上传到Airtable
我们找到EartTable的API文档,点击BaseData中的UploadAttachment,里面有详细的配置说明
你可以复制这个Card,然后M1N,它就会自动帮你填充好,非常简单
需要我们注意的是,在URL这里需要我们填写BaseID与CardID,AttachmentField orName
看起来好像挺复杂的样子,但如果拆解开来看的话其实是非常简单
我们一个一个来看,它的base ID就是你表格中连接的这部分
.com后面斜杠区间部分
我这里是app888aqg
OK,我们把它复制连贴到N8n
那record ID就更简单了
就是前面get great yours输出的ID字段
直接给它拖过来就好了
最后一个attachment field name是什么呢
就是你生成的图片要把它更新到哪一列
另一列的表头
比如我这里让它上传到after里
所以我在这里就给它改名为after
接下来给它做一个Cordidial认证
跟前面是一样的
但是在创建这里需要注意一下
它的Name是Authorization没问题
需要输入Bear加空格
然后再加你的Token
OK,Page完成之后
我们把生成的文件上传上去
Fill这里需要把转化成64位字符串的Data拖过来
OK点击测试显示已经上传成功了
我们在AirTable中也成功获取到了图片
效果还是非常的不错
其实到这里图片生成到上传的流程就完成了
为了让这个偏良生成图片的工作流能更严谨的运转起来呢
我在后面给它加了状态更改跟if循环
状态更改就是一个产品图跑完生成好图片之后把它改为完成
if循环就是让它返回去继续寻找在生成的字段
直到所有的产品图都生成完成
OK我们看一下这个状态更改是如何设置的
基础配置跟前面是一样的
着重说一下不一样的点
它的operation这里是一个create or update
所以下面会有一个mapping color mode
映射模式
这里我选的是手动映射
我们需要做一个columnus to match
选择要匹配的列
那如果匹配成功了
那就是更新
如果匹配不成功呢
就代表是创建
我这里用的是ID
也就是前面获取到的RecordID
接下来就是状态修改了
需要把状态改成完成
这样一旦前面跑完图片上传成功
就会自动更新为完成
OK我们点击测试一下
OK现在已经跑完了
回到AirTable看一下
刚才的代声程已经变成完成了
我们继续来看一下F节点
我这里设置的是当前面的节点状态变为完成
然后继续回到get greater raws
查找新的再生成的产品信息
为了避免图片跟描述的错位
我在fall节点里设置了只能执行一次的设置
这样它就一次只能输出一张图片
OK这样整个工作流的设置就完成了
我在这里准备了几个产品图
我们来测试一下它批量处理的能力怎么样
在这里我用的是text URL
所以需要手动出发
操作步骤是我们需要在N8N先运行工作流
然后在Airtable中点击运行
它会跳转提示
Workflow with ladder
就代表运行成功了
如果这里你设置的是production URL
你需要做的是
就是要先激活工作流
然后点击运行就好了
如果你是自动运行的话
可能看不到它的运行状态
看不到也没关系
你可以在Execution看它的执行路径
OK我们回到Airtable
我们看一下第一个已经执行完成了
我给的描述词是
男人在太空中坐在座椅上休息
要突出座椅的舒适性
原始图片就是一张座椅的图片
我们看一下它的生成效果怎么样
虽然它的椅子朝向变了
但是细节保持得很好
我们想要的场景也很完整
它给生成了一个穿着宇航服的男人
正坐在太空中休息
OK,第二张也生成出来了
而且帮我们把状态改成了完成这是我让一把椅子出现在茶桌边的场景整体是没有太大问题的在这里我想分享一下当生成的图片不符合你的要求时
我们如何编辑
像这个耳机的案例
我的原始图片其实是无线耳机
但是它给我生成了有线的
所以我要对描述词进行二次编辑
我们给它改成大熊猫带着无线耳机听歌
并且把它的状态改成待生成
这样工作留在循环时发现还有带生成的,就会重新执行
需要等一会儿,我们先看一下服装这个案例
真的也是非常让人惊讶
因为我的原始图片只是一个衣服的照片
但它给我生成出来的从穿着到场景都非常的逼真
而且衣服细节保留的也很完整
而且让人诟病了手指数量问题也都解决了
OK,我们看到耳机,art边界的图片已经生成好了
那IG是无限的了,但是logo没了,所以我们需要继续给它补充描述
大熊猫要侧坐着,然后露出完整的IG logo
OK,我们点击运行等待一下
OK,生成好了,这样就很完美了
同时我们也能注意到,这三次的微调其实它只是帮我们改了细节
在场景跟熊猫形象上没有太大的变化
这也说明Nano Banana在细节微调这块处理的有多棒了
那其他图片就不一一展示了
总结一下的话
大家可以在写描述词的时候尽可能的写的详细全面
方便AR更好的理解你的需求
OK,接下来我们看一下图片合成的工作流
这个时候我们给他两张原始图片
让他根据我们的要求融合起来
你可以是产品家模特
也可以是产品家场景
先看一下合成效果
我给她衣服跟一个模特
她生成了模特穿着衣服带走秀的图片
可乐加美女生成了美女拿着可乐带逛街的图片
我给她一个沙发加坐着的男人
生成了男人坐在沙发上休息的图片
然后给她葡萄加雪山
就生成了葡萄从雪山上长出来的图片
看上去是比较天马行空了
但其实我想表达的是
当你的朋友或家人无法满足你无理的要求时
AR可以满足你
OK,我们来看一下图片合成的工作流是如何设置的
听起来好像图片合成更复杂一些
但实际上在配置起来跟图片生成工作流很像
而且我个人觉得FOR对图片合成更友好一些
他把所有产品处理完成之后一次输出到ARTBALL的成功率
要比图片合成的成功率高得多
而且速度也会更快一些
我们看一下石涛图片合成的工作流做了哪些修改
第一部分是图片信息的获取
它的配置其实是一样的
当然你需要先在表格中配置好你需要的字段
设置好触发按钮跟webhook的连接
第二部分我们来看一下在创建图片做了哪些改动
先看Fall节点创建图片
它需要调整的是Zeson部分
在原来的基础上增加了一个图片
就是模特图的URL
也就是说我们需要把两个原始图片放在一块
它会根据我们的需求对它进行合成
然后这里我在后面增加了一个获取状态节点
这个是为了获取生成图片是否完成
因为这个流程它会一次性生成全部的图片
所以它的生成时长是不可控的
我们只能通过节点来确保图片全部生成完成
然后在执行后面的操作
否则就会出现报错的情况
OK在右边可以看到它的sliders是Completed
就代表完成了
然后呢通过F节点判断
如果这个字段是完成
那就走获取结果
如果没有完成呢
就让它等待5秒
然后再重新获取状态
直到图片生成完成
OK后面的下载图片
然后上载AirTable配置就是一样了
我们测试一下效果
点击运行Webhook
然后到Airtable
紧急运行测试一下
状态要记得调整为代升程
否则是无法运行的
现在工作流正在执行
在Airtable中陆续写入
效果依旧完美
这样两个工作流的配置就弄好了
他们两个整体的搭建思路也是非常一致的
对比一下他们优缺点
生存图片的工作流
优点是我们可以控制它
一次生存一张图片
会更严谨不会出错
但是缺点呢就是速度比较慢
那图片合成的工作流呢
它可以一次生成多张图片
增成速度较快
缺点呢可能会出现原始图片
该描述此错位的情况
大家可以自己体验一下
然后根据自己的需求自行选择
OK最后兑现前面的承诺
跟大家分享更便宜的API调用平台
一个呢是Keya
它用NanoBurner生成一张图片是0.2美元
几乎是负押的五折
当然这个也是需要充值续费才能使用的
那如果你不想充值
只是想免费体验一下呢
可以用这个Flores
它每个月会赠送1000积分
你可以用它免费生成25张图片
那OK今天的视频到这就结束了
希望对你有所启发
如果你觉得对你有帮助的话呢
也欢迎大家点赞订阅分享
你的支持是我创作的最大动力
那就下个视频见吧